[Music]
today I want to do something I've never
done on the channel and that's a basic
level video for firebase over the past
year I've created close to a hundred
videos covering intermediate to advanced
level concepts but I've never really
talked about why I use firebase and why
I think it's an excellent platform for
building apps I'm going to take you
through all the main features using
nothing but JavaScript and you don't
really need to have any coding
experience to follow on with this video
if you're new here make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and follow along with the code
on angular firebase comm so I originally
started in web development when Ruby on
Rails was powering things like Twitter
and Airbnb at the time it seemed like
magic because it made the backend so
much easier to develop but firebase
takes this to a whole new level by
completely abstracting away the backend
firebase doesn't pay me to say these
things I use it for my clients for three
main reasons the first one is the
developer experience it's well
documented easy to use and the team has
a really good culture of listening to
developer feedback the second factor is
minimization of cost firebase is free
for all of your small experimental
projects and then scales up in a linear
way based on your user growth and design
choices I really dislike platforms that
get you in on a free tier and then start
charging you 500 bucks a month once you
reach a certain threshold and the final
factor is the maximization of time I
want to create the most amount of value
in the least amount of time and I think
firebase facilitates that really well
and hopefully you'll agree with me there
when we finish writing the code for this
video to follow along you just need an
editor like BS code and nodejs installed
on your local system after that you can
go to firebase and create a new project
a project is just a container for
resources on Google cloud platform such
as your database file storage web
hosting and things like that you can
manage all of your app resources from
the firebase admin console and your
project can span across multiple
platforms firebase provides software
developer kits for the web iOS Android
unity and several others your project is
identified by the credentials that you
see here and they can integrate
seamlessly with other api's on Google
cloud platform so if you want to
implement something like cloud vision or
Google Maps you can do that with the
click of a button now that we have our
project created we're going to install
the firebase come
line tools by running NPM install fire
based tools flag G to install it
globally now I want to show you how
quick and easy it is to create and
deploy a project from the command line
so I've just opened up an empty folder
in BS code and then I'm pulling up the
terminal window and running firebase and
net hosting that's going to create a few
files for us the first one is firebase
JSON which holds all of our hosting
roles and then that firebase RC file is
just a script to identify our project
the public folder with index.html is our
actual app what it's doing is importing
the firebase web SDK in the head of the
document and you can import these one by
one so if you only need the database you
don't have to import all the other
modules as well so that can be a big
help with your page load performance
then you'll notice all these script tags
have defer on them that just tells a web
browser not to execute the script until
the page is finished loading from there
if we go down to the body of the
document we have another script tag
which is going to have all the actual
firebase SDK resources initialized and
available to us we're going to replace
the script with our own basic JavaScript
app but for now let's go ahead and serve
our app locally by running firebase
serve this is going to spin up a web
server locally on port 5,000 we can just
paste that into a browser and start
testing our app locally you should see
this default app which is just the
content directly in that index.html file
we can take this a step further and
deploy our app to a Live hosted URL
that's accessible on the Internet
all we have to do is run firebase deploy
that will give us back a URL and now we
can view our app live on the Internet
and this is actually a lot more powerful
than it seems on the surface because the
app is deployed with an ssl certificate
so we immediately have support for HTTPS
in the URL in addition it uses Google's
content delivery network which will
cache and serve all of your static
resources in a highly performant way now
that we know how to deploy our app let's
go back into the index.html and delete
all the boilerplate code except for the
main imports in the head of the document
then down in the body I'm going to point
our script tag to a new file called App
j/s that's where we're going to write
all
actual code then we can create that file
from the command line by running touch
public slash app J s the next thing I'm
going to do is bring up the browser
window side by side and run firebase
serves so we can check out the changes
that we make now I want to show you how
you can use firebase to manage your user
authentication in the past user
authorization but with firebase we can
do it in a few lines of code I just have
a simple HTML button here that will fire
this Google login function when clicked
then inside of app J s we want to make
sure to run our code after the document
content has loaded because firebase
won't be available until after that
point once the content has loaded we can
access the firebase resources under this
firebase namespace for example if we
call firebase app and then console.log
it it should give us an object with all
of our firebase credentials and other
things attached to that object you don't
have to do that but if you want to make
sure that firebase is available that's
one way to find out before we can
actually log in we need to go into the
firebase console under authentication
and enable the methods that we want to
use so in this case we want to use
Google as the OAuth provider but we
could also do things like email password
anonymous Twitter Facebook github etc
from there let's write a function that
will log the user in the first thing we
need to do is to find that provider that
we want to use which in this case would
be the firebase auth Google auth
provider from there we can reference the
firebase off library and call sign in
with pop-up passing at that provider as
an argument and that's literally all the
code that it takes to login the user
with Google this operation happens
asynchronously which means it returns a
promise whenever we have a promise we
can attach then to it which will give us
the user once that promise resolves so
we're saying sign in with pop-up then
when we have a user let's set that user
as a variable then we can write their
display name to the Dom and we'll also
console.log the user object all of the
user information will come from the
actual Google account if we go ahead and
click on login with Google button it's
going to bring up a pop-up window where
the user will log in to their actual
Google account then it's going to
execute any code inside of that then
block firebase uses J
some web tokens for authentication which
means there's an encrypted token on the
browser now that identifies this user if
you want to see that token you can just
go into the browser and type in local
storage and you can see the current user
session there JSON web tokens are much
easier to work with compared to cookies
especially for JavaScript applications
like angular and react I won't get into
the details here but I do cover that in
some of my more advanced videos if we go
back into the firebase console now
you'll see that our user is created in
the firebase authentication tab we can
use this to disabled accounts update
email templates if you're using email
password auth perform text message
verification and abuse some basic
analytics so that wraps up user auth now
let's move into the cornerstone of
firebase which is its database as of
October 2017
we have two different database options
both of them being no sequel databases
we have real time database and cloud
firestore you can use both of them
together but more often than not you're
going to choose between one or the other
and the best way to do that in my
opinion is to analyze the pricing for
the real time database were charged $5
per gigabyte stored and $1 per gigabyte
downloaded for firestore on the other
hand were charged 18 cents per gigabyte
stored but we're also charged for each
individual document read and write
operation so what that boils down to is
that if you have a really simple data
set that is read frequently you would
use the real time database but for a
larger more complex relational data set
you'd want to use cloud firestore in the
majority of cases I find that cloud
firestore ends up being the better
choice so that's where we're going to
start enable the database and start it
in test mode which is going to disable
any security rules then the actual
database itself is structured as
collections of documents it follows a
pattern similar to MongoDB which is the
most widely adopted no sequel database
in the world and if you're interested in
data modelling check out episode 85 the
first thing we'll do is create a
collection which is just a container for
documents and then we'll add our first
document to it every document has a
unique ID which you can create yourself
or you can have it automatically
generated in this case I'm going to
create myself and call it first post
then the actual data that we consume
from our app will be set as fields on
this document the structure is similar
to a JavaScript object or an object in
any other programming language we can
then use these fields to pull a subset
of documents from a collection based on
whatever condition we want to pass to it
that'll make a little more sense when we
start building some queries in our
front-end code one of the coolest things
about firebase is that your user
authentication system is directly tied
to your database under the rules tab you
can write expressive statements that
define the backend security logic for
your app for example if you had a
certain set of documents that only a
logged in user should see you'd be able
to do that here with a single line of
code it's beyond the scope of this video
but needless to say it's a very
important part of building a fully
secured app then the last thing
firestore can do is build indices by
default you'll have an index for every
field on a given document but if you
want to query by multiple fields you may
need to create your own custom index now
getting back to our front-end app I'm
going to replace the firebase database
import with firestore and the first
thing I want to do is just retrieve and
read that document that we created in
the database console so first we make a
reference to fire store as a variable
named DB then we make a reference to the
collection by calling DB collection
posts and then we reference the specific
document ID which I gave a custom ID of
first post so at this point we have a
reference to the document and we could
use that reference to retrieve it listen
to it in real time
or update and delete it what we want to
do right now is just retrieve it and be
done with it so to retrieve it we just
call get which is an asynchronous
operation that returns a promise that
resolves with the actual document data
that we saved in fire store so I'll set
the data as a variable and I'll write
the title and timestamp to the browser
window now if we refresh the page we
should see that document information
printed to the screen so that's pretty
cool but one of the major benefits of
firebase is that we can listen to data
changes in real time so if you have some
day
it's shared between multiple users and
that data changes somewhere all of your
users are going to be notified at that
exact moment of the change that would be
an extremely difficult feature to build
from scratch but we can do it with a few
modifications to the code we just wrote
so instead of calling get we're going to
replace that with on snapshot instead of
returning a promise this is going to
return a real-time stream that we can
listen to with a callback function so we
can get rid of then and we'll just copy
and paste all of our previous code
inside of this callback function every
time the document changes it's going to
emit a new document to this function and
we can handle it accordingly in this
case the browser should write another
line every time a change occurs in
firestore so let's go ahead and change
the title and you can see here on the
right that it's automatically updated in
the browser if your app does anything
that's real time in nature this is going
to be one of the most powerful aspects
of firebase for you in addition to
reading documents we can also update
documents from our client-side code what
I'm going to do here is set up a form
input and every time this input changes
it's going to run an update to firestore
so we'll set up a function called update
post and then we'll make a reference to
the document just like we did before but
this time we'll call update and pass it
the information that the user had typed
into the form when data is updated from
your app firestore does something really
cool called optimistic updates or
latency compensation if you have a
real-time listener on the data like we
set up before it will update the view
immediately so your user doesn't have to
wait for a server to respond which might
take a second or two and potentially
hurt the user experience in most cases
though we're probably not going to be
reading a single document but trying to
query a collection of documents to show
you that I'm creating a collection of
products where every product has a price
and a name one of the major benefits of
firestore is that you can query multiple
documents in a very expressive way back
in the code will first make a reference
to the products collection and then if
we want to get a subset of the documents
in that collection we can call where
and where takes three different
arguments first it's the field that we
want to sort by which in this case is
the price then it takes an operator
which could be equal to greater than
greater than equal to and so on then the
third and final argument is the actual
value so in this case we want all the
products whose price is greater than $10
then just like we did with the document
read we can call get and instead of
returning a single document it's going
to return an array of documents so
really the only difference is that we
need to loop over these documents to get
the data for each one for each document
in the array I'm writing that name and
price to the screen so we have our
wrench and our chain saw which are both
over $10 if we change the operator to
greater than or equal to 10 dollars then
the query will also include products
that are equal to $10 if we want to
check for just equality we can change
the operator to equals and then it's
only going to return the hammer in
addition to the wear method we can also
use order by to return documents in a
specific order if we want to retrieve
all of our products ordered from highest
price to lowest price then we can say
order by price descending and we'll get
our products back in that order and we
can also limit the number of documents
that are returned which is really
important when you're working with a
large collection simply chain the limit
method to any query and that will cap
the number of documents that come back
in the array that wraps up the database
section now we're ready to get started
with firebase storage storage is just a
cloud storage bucket that is also tied
to your firebase project this is where
you might put user-generated content
like uploaded images videos things like
that so the first thing we want to do is
go into the rule section and currently
it's set up to only allow authenticated
users to upload files but we want to
change that for now we're just going to
let anybody upload files to our storage
bucket back in the index.html in our
front-end app I'm setting up a form
input that is set to type file then on
the change event we're going to run a
function called upload file and pass it
this files as the argument I am also
going to display an image tag that
currently doesn't have a source
but we'll set it source asynchronously
after the upload is complete and the
JavaScript will make a reference to the
storage library in a similar way that we
did with the database we will reference
a path in that storage bucket but in the
storage bucket we do that by calling
child and then in this case we'll just
pass it a static image name of horse dot
JPEG with this reference we can either
upload a file or download an existing
file URL our form inputs going to return
a file list so we'll just take the first
item of that list with item zero and
then to upload the file all we have to
do is called a reference put file we can
run code when the upload is complete by
chaining then to it it's going to return
some data about the upload itself
including the snapshot download URL what
we want to do in this case is take that
URL and then apply it to the source of
that image tag that we set in the HTML
if we go ahead and choose a file it's
going to start the upload and then
you'll see it updated in the document
after a couple seconds if we jump back
to the firebase console we can also see
the image in the storage bucket there as
well that was super easy and now we can
get on to my favorite part of firebase
which is cloud functions we're going to
do something very simple but if you want
to see cloud functions do things like
hit machine learning api's handle
payments send emails and things like
that
check out the functions tag on the main
website functions can be thought of as
your own nodejs server that runs on
demand so instead of having one giant
monolithic framework that handles all of
your back-end code you write micro
services that perform a specific
function and anything that you can do in
nodejs you can do in a function you can
install any NPM packages you want into
your functions environment and the
node.js ecosystem is huge so that opens
the door for a lot of creativity we can
initialize functions in our project by
running firebase and net functions
that's going to create a new directory
called functions which isolates all of
our back-end code you can trigger
functions in a variety of ways but the
way we're going to do it is with a fire
store database trigger what that means
is we're going to listen to a specific
document
and when a new document is created there
it's going to trigger that function code
to run on the back end what we're going
to do in this case is just send a
message from the function back to the
database the idea here is to show you
how information can be shared between
your back-end code and your database
inside the functions directory we have a
package JSON which defines all of our
third-party NPM dependencies then we can
define our functions in the index J SVO
and another unique thing we can do here
is use the firebase admin SDK the admin
SDK can only be used in a back-end
environment like cloud function and it
will bypass any security rules that
you've defined in your firebase app the
first thing we want to do is say exports
followed by the name of our function
which in this case is send message
then we'll point this function to fire
store on documents in the products
collection the brackets make the Product
ID a wild-card so it's going to run this
function every time a new document is
created inside this on create trigger we
need to return a promise and it's going
to give us access to this event object
that has some information about the
incoming requests in firestore we can
get the document ID from the event
params and then we can get the data
inside that document from the event data
data and in this demo we're only
interested in that name of the actual
product so now the cloud functions
receive some data and it wants to send
that data back as an update to the same
document so to do that we say admin fire
store and then reference that document
path then the last thing we'll do is
return the actual update operation which
is a promise in other words we're
returning the update operation from this
function and the function will terminate
as soon as that promise resolves the
last thing we need to do is run firebase
deploy functions and that will send our
code up to firebase you can verify that
it was deployed by going to the
functions tab and you should now see
that function in there with some basic
analytics then if you switch over to
fire store and add a document to the
products collection you should see the
update run after a second or so of
latency
so that wraps up the main development
resources in a fire based project
authentication database storage hosting
and functions but when it comes to
native mobile apps there's still a huge
number of features that we haven't even
looked at so let's quickly go over some
of the highlights there the first area
is testing and stability if you're like
most developers you probably don't enjoy
writing a lot of tests but thankfully
firebase has a robo testing tool where
you can just upload your app build and
it will run a suite of tests that look
for issues that commonly cause mobile
apps to crash and you can review the
screenshot results of every test the
next thing is analytics and there's a
ton of analytic tools in firebase but
the one that really stands out to me is
stream view it gives you a global
geographic representation of your entire
user base in real time then you might
want to use trending data there to send
push notifications to your users
firebase makes it easy to send out push
notifications based on a user segments
specific topic or just to a single
device you can also set up a be testing
for your notifications and track the
conversion rates of each one that you
send I'm going to go ahead and wrap up
my tour a firebase there if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you're serious about building apps
with firebase check out angularfire
BassPro where you get access to a whole
bunch of exclusive resources designed to
help you build and ship your app faster
thanks for watching and I'll see you
soon
[Music]